[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
que en directo américa de francés 24 y
hasta conmigo lista en el estudio
daniela blandón daniela buena mañana
vamos entonces a hablar de algo que está
en todo el ojo del huracán con estas
tensiones entre occidente y ucrania a
danny porque últimamente se ha hablado
mucho entonces del nord stream 2 como
parte de estas tensiones también por
supuesto de otro protagonista que nombré
al principio y es rusia frente a ucrania
le pregunto porque raúl muy buenos días
pues lo quiero invitar a que comencemos
escuchando la amenaza que lanzó el
presidente de eeuu joe biden el lunes
después de reunirse con el canciller
olaf scholz
si rusia invade eso significa que
tanques o tropas crucen la frontera de
ucrania nuevamente entonces ya no habrá
nuestro in 2
le pondremos sin
duda pero como era eso exactamente dado
que el proyecto estaba bajo el control
de alemania
lo haremos de lo prometo podremos
hacerlo
ahora si le cuento raúl porque es
importante este es un proyecto
energético diseñado para que el gigante
ruso gazprom duplica sus envíos de gas
directamente a alemania por el mar
báltico sin tener que pasar por ucrania
de ahí que quien diga que va a dejar de
recibir millonarias regalías y por eso
es muy polémico el tubo ya están
construya está construido pero no está
en funcionamiento y espera la aprobación
final alemana ahora volvemos a eeuu
porque entonces el interés de washington
en este proyecto y como el presidente yo
bailé dice que pues yo tengo la decisión
firme
raúl es que tanto estados unidos como la
unión europea creen que el proyecto
aumenta
energética de rusia y que moscú puede
usarlo como un arma política y alemania
trata de no hablar tan durito vaart
raúl y es porque la mitad del gas que
consume hoy viene de rusia recuerde mi
nombre yo voy a decir a arturito danny
la unión europea presentó entonces
entonces esperada ley de chips y le
pregunto en qué consiste bueno primero
le digo que la esencia principal es
dejar de depender de países como estados
unidos o los países asiáticos
concretamente se busca que el bloque
comunitario produzca una quinta parte de
aquí al 2030 de chips nuestra
corresponsal en bruselas esther herrera
nos explicó más detalle en el siguiente
informe
la comisión europea ha presentado su
esperada ley de chips el objetivo es que
europa aumente la producción mundial de
estos semiconductores tan importantes
para sectores como el del automóvil y
también el de los ordenadores así se
espera que de aquí a 2030 el 20 por
ciento de la producción mundial de chips
se haga en europa además europa sobre
todo lo que quieres también en reducir
la dependencia que tiene respecto a
china y taiwán que crean gran parte de
estos chips más aún cuando en los
últimos meses ha habido graves problemas
de escasez y entonces esto también ha
provocado que muchas empresas europeas
hayan tenido que paralizar su producción
debido a su incapacidad de poder tener
estos semiconductores a tiempo la idea
es que hay una inversión pública inicial
de aproximadamente 30 mil millones de
euros para la creación de fábricas de
chips también para atraer inversión
privada y para la investigación en total
se espera movilizar aproximadamente
45.000 millones de euros bruselas
también facilitará las ayudas y los
subsidios para crear
a orillas de chips que son de por sí ya
muy caras bruselas asegura que su plan
es muy parecido al que ya presentó eeuu
recientemente con una inversión de 50
mil millones de dólares pues danny
cambiamos de información nos venimos a
nuestro continente porque en argentina
los petroleros se van a una huelga
porque así es raúl raúl alberto están
reclamando un aumento salarial que
mitigue la pérdida de poder adquisitivo
pues con la alta inflación de este país
la protesta es liderada por el sindicato
de petróleo y gas privado que aglutina
unos 25 mil trabajadores de las
provincias de río negro neuquén y la
pampa justamente neuquén aloja al
yacimiento de vaca muerta del que ya
hemos hablado acá que es la cuarta
reserva de petróleo no convencional del
mundo y la segunda de gas natural y
donde operan varias empresas petroleras
entre ellas la estatal y pf dan y le
pregunto por los indicadores entonces
los mercados mundiales están al alza los
inversionistas esperando señales de los
bancos centrales sobre si van a subir o
no las tasas de interés para controlar
la inflación
tokio y australia y en europa londres y
parís también abrieron la jornada al
alza y fráncfort cae levemente para
finalizar que nos trae como cifra el día
20 como 76 millones de empleos formales
se sostenía méxico con corte a dinero y
según el gobierno esta cifra es mayor en
150.000 a la que había antes de la
pandemia pero lo más preocupante allí es
la informalidad no se nos olvide bueno
la informalidad como siempre que golpea
nuestro continente y nuestra región
danny gracias por toda la información
vamos a ver ahora nuestro reportaje